a
ahora
el costo humano de la guerra en
afganistán es de cerca de 2500 militares
estadounidenses
3.846 contratistas cerca de 66 mil
militares afganos más de 47 mil civiles
de afganistán más de 51.000 talibanes
444 voluntarios y 72 periodistas esto
sin tener en cuenta los más de 20 mil
soldados heridos en combate según la
universidad de brown de eeuu se gastó
más de un billón de dólares en la guerra
sin embargo aunque se haya acabado
quedan todavía grandes facturas por
pagar por ejemplo el costo para mantener
los cerca de 4 millones de veteranos de
guerra de eeuu desde septiembre del 2001
hasta el 2050 puede llegar hasta los 2,5
billones de dólares así lo estima la
universidad de brown el alianza con
harvard sin embargo pese a estas cifras
eeuu mantiene su presencia militar en
varios países entre ellos
[Música]
o
150.000 integrantes de las fuerzas
armadas británicas integraron la
coalición de los aliados en la guerra en
afganistán tras los ataques terroristas
de al-qaeda del 11 de septiembre de 2001
esa presencia británica se concentró en
la región del helmand en el sur de
afganistán según el gobierno británico
457 militares perdieron la vida durante
esta guerra desde 2014 las tropas
británicas dejaron de participar en los
combates
entonces los 750 uniformados que se
mantenían en terreno afgano hacían parte
de el grupo de la otan que se encargaba
de dar asesoría y entrenamiento al
ejército de afganistán
el gasto militar en estos últimos 20
años según the gardian ha sido de 37 mil
millones de libras esterlinas
a finales de junio salieron los últimos
soldados alemanes de afganistán tras una
misión de 20 años el gobierno describió
como histórica e intensa también fue una
operación muy costosa según revelaron
medios alemanes este año los
contribuyentes pagaron 12 mil 500
millones de euros por la participación
alemana en esas operaciones
internacionales en afganistán también
fue una operación muy grande y de hecho
la ministra de defensa alemana anne
criticó kagawa agradeció a los 150.000
militares que participaron en esas
operaciones durante los últimos 20 años
según cifras oficiales de las fuerzas
militares alemanas
59 soldados alemanes murieron en
afganistán
[Música]